I think that so much of the world's  unhappiness and anxiety is based on the  fact that we eliminated or demonized  competition at the Youth Level the idea  that eighth place trophies are a good  idea is a huge mistake in my one  person's opinion you don't want kids to  feel bad because they're not good at  baseball but to completely eliminate  Merit and the human Spirit has led to a  lot of collateral issues I think  competition is good I think losing is  good I think crying after a baseball  game is good and I think we've created  it to be bad and I think it's worth the  debate in society we're blaming a lot of  unhappiness on social media social media  is the proxy what's underneath that is  people's inability to have judgment from  others